muy buenos días Ángela aquí hace ya dos
horas que han abierto los centros de
votación como el que tengo a mi espalda
y los votantes podrán venir hasta las 8
de la tarde a las 7 de la mañana Hace
dos horas se han empezado también a
contar los votos anticipados esos votos
que han llegado por correo y esto podría
ralentizar como decía podría como decías
podría ser que no conociéramos al
ganador en horas o incluso días porque
aquí los resultados están muy reñidos
como digo como veis detrás poco a poco
van llegando los votantes aquí en
Filadelfia hay más de un millón de más
de un millón de votantes registrados y
en Pensilvania 8,7 la mayoría de ellos
demócratas por eso se entiende que el
presidente en la esa recta final de la
campaña pasará por aquí este fin de
semana porque la participación va a ser
crucial para los demócratas para poder
hacerse En este estado con ese escaño
que hay en el senado que es lo más
importante que está juego aquí ahora
mismo además de la gobernación bien y
entre tanto que ha pasado con esos
papeletas de votación que han sido de
vueltas mami
Sí pues Ángel al día 1 de noviembre la
Corte Suprema de aquí de Pensilvania
dijo que se iban a echar para atrás
todas aquellas boletas que no tuvieran
la fecha escrita o que la fecha
estuviera incorrecta así fue miles de
papeletas se han echado para atrás de
vuelta y esto ha provocado que hoy mucha
más gente salga a la calle a votar
porque quieren asegurarse de que su voto
cuenta por su parte el candidato
demócrata John ftherman junto con su
equipo han presentado presentaron ayer
una demanda Federal para que estas
boletas se cuenten porque como os decía
la participación va a ser crucial aún
así vemos que hay mucha seguridad mucho
control esta señora que veis detrás de
mí es una voluntaria que vela para que
las elecciones transcurran como dice
ella como debe ser se han enviado 24
observadores se han enviado observadores
electorales a 24 estados algo que se
suele hacer pero este año más que nunca
es muy interesante que hemos hablado con
el comisionado electoral de aquí de
Pensilvania y nos dice que esperan una
gran participación